I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
oh hi mark I love my eyes tiny anything
that's what time
Superman for the quest for peace is one
of the worst movies ever made I
genuinely do not think there's any
debate this is a broken movie that was
so chopped up in editing so plagued with
production issues a half an hour of this
movie was removed from the entire
runtime
I have reviewed this before but never in
Hilario city form and I thought to do
that I would bring on the same person
who helped me get through Batman and
Robin and that would be my good friend
John Flickinger aka the flick pick as my
horrible impression either guys my name
is John I come from a magical land
called the flick pit channel so thanks
for having me back stuck man to do
another hilarious of your review the
last time we talked about bat nipples
and this time we're talking about
Superman the quest for suck think the
last time I watch this movie was in 1997
on a VHS tape at my uncle's house and
yeah whatever so anyway I bought the
movie on Amazon I'm not proud to say
that so yeah let's just do this this
movie was made by a production company
called Canon they are a notoriously
terrible production company from the 80s
who made some of the worst action movies
ever made now that's not to say those
movies weren't amazing in their own way
they were trying to save their
production company from going under and
they thought a movie like Superman 4
could be the film that did that and it
really just made it even worse so this
movie opens with some astronauts in
space and of course some sort of
disaster happens and you're watching the
film and you're thinking okay you know
this could be a movie it's possibly
better than Superman 3 who knows we'll
see what have all my god what the hell
was that get used to that shot of
Superman flying by the way because
you're gonna see it a lot in fact I took
the liberty of counting enjoy
it's mind-boggling to me that they
thought no one would notice that or at
least that no one would care we care you
guys could have done maybe two or three
of them maybe haven't looked this way or
look up or maybe kind of close one I
know the exact same one every single
time but the one that's always bothered
me the most is this one right here in
this subway sequence where Superman
flies past his crowd of people standing
in the subway and the timing is
completely wrong you have this man he's
a heroic figure with a cape and a blue
suit he flies past these people but
they're not looking at him they're
looking behind him because they couldn't
time the sequence right with the
live-action background it's like hey
lady why are you looking at the subway
tiles
Superman just flew by now in all
fairness when discussing Superman for
the quests are suck we could probably
stop every 25 seconds during this movie
and talk shit about it but for the sake
of all humanity and time and my lack of
sleep we're just going to start with
this scene right here so the guy from
two and a Half Men that Charlie Sheen
the other one who no one talks about her
makes means and doesn't claim that he
has Tigers blood he helps break his
uncle Lex Luthor out of prison by
tricking two guards to get into a pit
mobile and then driving them off of a
cliff now pay close attention to the car
a simple stunt but they use a shitty
model Dingling on a string that they
probably bought at Walmart for minutes
before they shot the scene look at the
bottom of this model car right here it's
all flat and it looks like it's dangling
from a string
they couldn't even buy a shitty pit
mobile to push off of a cliff they had
to buy a $5 Hot Wheels toy from Walmart
to do it so there you have it you have
this little toy model dangling from a
stream going down into this big pit and
you at least expect it to blow up with
some firecrackers or something no no no
that would cost too much money how much
money would that cost
I don't know like $6 they don't even
show the car blowing up
right huh
that's what this movie is just lazy
shitty effects for an hour and a half
but you know what that's not even the
thing that bothers me most about the
scene it's the fact that you have these
two ordinary prison guards crawling out
of this pit after they were in a car
after it went off a cliff 200 feet
crashed blew up and there okay
they just crowded this pit and they were
just like what happened it's like hey
why is this movie all that Superman I
get that he's super but we have two
prison guards over here who are
indestructible as well
nobody cares okay so Clark goes back to
his family farm in Smallville and we
know this because this appears do they
really think we're that dumb that we
can't tell this is the Kent farm in
Smallville I mean they have to let us
know and in this film's first display of
very random Superman powers he simply
stares very hard at the ship he came in
as a kid and it vanishes from existence
let's hope he doesn't take a nice long
look at Lois one day and just make her
disappear after talking to some guy
who's interested in buying the Kent farm
he then takes a baseball and smashes it
into orbit that ball should have
shattered into a million pieces as well
as the bat I mean he'll Benny from the
Sandlot busted the guts out of a ball
and that thing was still on the grass
definitely not in space I mean it's only
12 o'clock and I just ruin the whole day
for us no you didn't that's the most
amazing thing I ever saw anybody got
another ball no no well then ain't okay
because now we can't play no more I'm
just gonna think about the same lot for
the rest of this review if that's okay
with you guys and immediately we get
another Superman rescue scene it's
almost like they just cut out all
relevant character moments for just the
big Superman parts I think a guy Manning
the subway train starts choking or
something because it's so poorly
executed that I can actually tell what
the problem is
but Superman saves the day flies off and
Louis is like hey Superman you kind of
look like someone but I've always
laughed my ass off at this last line I
know Superman is like American superhero
guy eh America but this is just too much
I'd like all the people back there to
know that our subway system is still the
safest and most reliable means of public
transportation thank you so there's this
horribly boring useless subplot about
this new guy in town who's trying to
take over the Daily Planet and turn it
into a terrible newspaper and his
daughter with glasses the size of
Superman's
fist and apparently she has a crush on
Clark Kent so there's like a weird love
triangle I guess I don't know it's just
it's this aspect of the movie I hated I
hated it watching this part of it I was
just so good just get to the dumb
nuclear man part please just anything
besides this okay the next thing up is
the museum scene we have a strand of
Superman's hair on display showcasing
just how powerful Superman is yeah you
have one strand of Superman's hair
holding up a thousand-pound weight and
then la dee da dee da you have the
villain of the movie Lex Luthor come in
and a shitty disguise he just taps on
the glass it breaks it's like first of
all why isn't this glass bulletproof I
mean you have an alien strand of hair
you think you might want to protect it
but that's I'm getting ahead of myself
and then mastermind Lex Luthor pulls out
a pair of bolt cutters just ordinary
bolt cutters
they're not like kryptonite encrypted or
specially made and he just cuts
Superman's hair and that's it
he takes it any leaves but let's back up
for a second in the realm of comic book
movie logic you can't cut Superman's
hair with an ordinary pair of bolt
cutters it's like that Superman's hair
you can't just cut that it takes effort
it takes something special not just a
pair of everyday bolt cutters but this
movie doesn't care the screenwriters
didn't care they never read a comic book
in their life nor did they care to they
were just like how can we easily
progress the plot in the laziest way
possible I just do that what then we
just cut away with the alarm blaring and
we never learned how Luthor escaped this
museum cameras didn't pick him up guards
didn't pick him up in fact there's
nobody looking for him after he escaped
from prison so here's where the movie's
actual plot starts to be
it just so randomly inserts this whole
thing about nuclear fear and that
everyone has nuclear bombs and we get to
this classroom scene with two horrific
aliyyil ADR moments one is the teacher
now I know you're all upset by the
crisis the best thing we can do is to
try to think positively and the other is
this young boy named Jeremy who
absolutely catapults this film's plot
into the stratosphere of dumb by wanting
Superman to rid the world of nuclear
weapons I tell you I'd write a letter to
that would do some good who's Santa
Claus no Superman I know who could do
some good who's Santa Claus no Superman
so Clark gets really stressed out about
this whole nuclear weapon thing and he
decides to tell Lois that he's Superman
by jumping off of a roof with her and
then we get this friggin scene where
they float around all over the world
absurd amounts of distances are
traversed in seconds shots are thrown
all over the place telling us well now
they're here well now they're there Lois
is wearing a dress she never appears
different now listen guys if you guys
are aspiring filmmakers or you want to
work in special-effects someday watch
this scene right here that how you don't
do green-screen before I say what I'm
going to say I understand that this
movie is called Superman
I understand it's about a man who can
fly I get that but can Lois Lane fly in
this movie I didn't think so
so why the fuck is she flying just look
at a few of these scenes right here Lois
Lane is flying side-by-side with
Superman he's holding her hand then he
lets go she continues to fly and it's
just like what the fuck is this in all
reality Lois Lane would be like this
holding on to Superman's Hannah she's
dangling at this point in the movie it's
no longer a Superman movie it's Peter
Pan someone sprinkle pixie dust I'm Lois
Lane and she's she's flying to Neverland
so Supes decides to do the nuclear
weapon thing and he gives his big speech
and Christopher Reeve giving a speech
it's great he is Superman to me this is
the one positive thing about this movie
Christopher Reeve he's great he is
Superman as far as I'm concerned and
it's cool seeing him give a speech but
it's like who cares you know and then we
get this montage where he somehow knows
where all these nukes are how does he
actually know this shoot here's all the
nukes
there's one there there's one there this
woman ok fly the best part of this whole
sequence is that he creates a giant net
in space filled with nuclear weapons
where'd he get this giant net you
probably made that with his weird-ass
Superman 4 powers he collects all the
nukes and he launches them into the Sun
now look I don't know too much about
space and the science around the Sun but
I can't imagine launching every nuclear
weapon on earth into the Sun would
really be a good idea it'd be a pretty
terrible idea I think so now we get more
of Luther planning his evil plans but
the best part of this scene are the
supporting actors in it we have Jim
Broadbent and Porkins
from Star Wars and the top men guy from
Raiders and Lieutenant Eckhart from
Batman that guy is the craziest guy like
look at all those roles use Porkins he's
just sitting there in Superman 4 he's
just sitting there I've got a problem
here
I'm in Superman 4 I can't hold it
so Luthor's plan is that with the DNA in
Superman's hair strand he will create a
being from the Sun called nuclear man to
fight and kill Superman
and it works nuclear man is born from
the Sun a literal fetus sprouts from the
Sun within seconds flings got these long
silver nails long blonde hair and a
dumbass costume the film does not care
to explain how Luthor did this he just
did it
now who is nuclear man well he's the yin
to the yang of Superman he's just a
shitty version of Superman who has a
bleached blond hair he looks like a
Chippendales dancer and he covers
himself in baby oil
yeah the summed up nuclear man kinda
looks like the shittier version of
Master sensei of Cobra Kai and the
Karate Kid so nuclear man somehow knows
to come to Luthor he just comes right to
where Luther is lands and he's like
hello I am nuclear man destroy Superman
by the way that's gene Hackman's voice
and we're instantaneously shown nuclear
man's weakness when he gets out of the
sunlight he just powers down I mean
Luthor even flat-out says that's his
vulnerability
that's the only way to be stopped could
they be any more obvious about how
Superman will eventually beat nuclear
man also what a horrible weakness you
can only fight in the Sun I mean if the
shame passes over this guy he's like mm
I could beat nuclear man all I'd have to
do is take a really big branch of a tree
and just hold it over him for a second
and he'd be like hmm so now we get
what's known as a comedy scene where
Superman and Clark have to be in the
same place at the same time and I
honestly got so bored here that I
started doodling in my notepad so Luthor
calls Superman on that high-frequency
sound that only Superman can hear and he
somehow knows to tell Superman this to
your left oh I'm gonna blow 20 stories
of that building how would he even
remotely know which direction to tell
Superman to look he has no idea where
Superman is this writing is horrendous
there is no excuse for that Superman
could be anywhere it could be in Alaska
it could be in I Antarctica it could be
in China
it could be anywhere how would you know
where to tell him where to look that's
so bad now let's talk about the epic
scene in Superman 4 where nuclear man
and Superman go head-to-head these two
Titans of godlike power collide for the
first time and what happens
they sort of awkwardly hug each other it
looks like ones trying to make out with
the other one and then they fall off of
a building and then we get some ass
juice inducing flying sequences once
again throughout this movie some random
stuff happens but then something amazing
happens it's at this point in the movie
for the first time ever were introduced
to Superman's secret power and what is
it not only does Superman have heat
vision he also has wall rebuilding
vision that's right Superman can rebuild
walls by looking at them huh
yeah and you know the saddest thing
about this is I'm pretty sure about 90%
of the FX budget went into this scene
just rebuilding a fucking wall Oh
Superman for and then after that some
more random stuff happens nuclear man
kind of just irritate Superman by
picking up stuff and putting it down
it's just like what are you doing dude
why do you exist and then the most
amazing thing happens it's where nuclear
man has long silver fake fingernails and
he bitch scratches Superman yeah he
doesn't punch him he doesn't choke him
out
bitch scratches oh there's no excuse for
this a gigantic slow-motion disaster in
which two men are just sort of like
fondling each other that's all this is
this might as well be like foreplay for
an eventual Superman nuclear man porno
for goodness sakes The Incredible Hulk
show with Bill Bixby had better fight
scenes this entire scene is so
horrendously unfinished and broken
Superman lives with Nicolas Cage is more
finished than this movie and they didn't
even make that this fight scene ends
with Superman getting scratched on the
neck by a nuclear man which somehow just
makes him start withering away he starts
losing his powers because of a scratch
nuclear man and again another crazy time
jump occurs and the only thing letting
us in on what's happening is Louis is
exposition and then another crazy time
jump happens another one with Clark
withering away like some old man looking
for that green crystal that he got when
he was a kid here is where the film
absolutely positively tanks in every way
it was awful already but now nuclear man
looks at a picture of The Daily Planet
newspaper and sees this new girl Lacey
and decides that he wants to find her
he's got a crush on this girl now and
yet another crazy time jump happens and
Superman just appears in Metropolis he's
back now because he found the green
crystal why was his sickness such a
problem if all he had to do is go crawl
in a hole pick up a green crystal and
that's it that's all we see he's all old
he's like green crystal and then he's
Superman again that's it that's all he
had to do was just pick up a green
crystal and now he's sugar vinegar
honestly this is unbelievable the fact
that this even saw the light of day is
astounding to me so nuclear man is now
in Metropolis because he wants to find
Laci I honestly want to know what he
wants to do what is his plan is he
planning on like getting some right cuz
it's not gonna happen I mean I didn't
you were born from the side like a
couple days ago probably no maybe was
six months ago with how this film
storytelling is and he starts destroying
things and hurting people and Superman
says this
don't do it the people Oh some terrible
line delivery stop don't do it them hey
Bob stop don't do I kept it Bob stop
don't do it so Superman Trix nuclear man
into going inside an elevator and then
drops him off on the moon and you really
got to love those space curtains the
moon has man this movie actually got
released okay I think it's that time
we're almost at the climax of the movie
and what is the climax of Superman for
well just get ready so once again in
Superman for nuclear man and superman
clash head-to-head and well I guess I'm
overstating something right there
because here's what happens
and then Superman and nuclear man
proceeded to keep fighting and it's like
two drunks in an alleyway they just kind
of hug each other and like caress each
other and a little bit of cuddling
happens and then nuclear man plant
Superman like a carrot
and then what does nuclear man do once
he almost defeats Superman well he just
flies off he goes back to earth kidnap
some chick and then takes her up into
space now keep in mind nuclear man is
nuclear man he can handle space but this
everyday average chick she can't like
why is she not dead by this point why
has her head not exploded she's in space
right now honestly there is too much
shit happening right now to even focus
on wow this girl is just floating around
in space wearing her high heels and
skirts
Superman moves the moon to block the Sun
so nuclear man loses all of his powers
instantaneously which of course we all
knew was going to happen
honestly if Superman were to move the
moon and obstruct the orbit around the
earth and everything we have tidal waves
and flooding and all kinds of absurd
weather problems on this earth but who
cares about any of that because who
really cares just just let the movie end
he drops nuclear man inside of a power
plant powering the city absurdly I guess
he saves Laci and she's like wow I can
breathe in space so Supes gives a
horrific ly edited speech you can tell
it was probably supposed to be a lot
longer than it actually is he captures
Luthor of course and we get the exact
same reused shot from Superman the movie
from 1978 ending our film that's right
they couldn't even do another one they
used the same shot
they just color corrected it to make it
look slightly different insanity ah so
that's Superman for the quest for peace
a terribly executed film where they had
no money whatsoever and it's a film with
nothing but special effects shots every
10 minutes and if you don't have the
budget or talent or time to even try to
attempt these effects it's probably best
you don't make a movie with a minute but
no one working on Superman for gave us
shit and they said no one cares let's do
it we have six dollars let's make a
movie and Superman for the quest for
peace along with many other movies that
came out around this time period is the
reason that the studio behind this movie
went out of business the studio also
made over-the-top with Sylvester
Stallone I like that movie so I can't
really talk shit about it alrighty so
that's my take on Superman for the quest
for peace and as much as I
hated watching this movie again I still
had fun making the video and now
hopefully I never have to talk about the
movie again I think I get all the hate
out and I feel better so anyway yeah
thanks for watching guys and thanks
Chris for having me back on your channel
I really appreciate it my name is John
I'll see you guys next time guys this
movie's horrible I hate it John and I
hate it everyone hates this movie it's
terrible thanks for watching our
hilarious 'ti review of Superman for the
quest for who gives a shit please
subscribe to John's channel if you get a
chance he makes really great content and
thank you John for coming along in this
video it was a ton of fun and speaking
of really crappy Superman things I hope
you guys check out my hilarious T review
I've already done for Supergirl in 1984
movie as well as my retro rewind of
superman 64 one of the worst video games
ever made where i actually sat down and
tried to play it stay tuned next week
because it is going to be a retro rewind
sunday I'm not sure what it'll be in my
new release reviews this week I'll let
you know what it's going to be thank you
guys so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes